our heavenly father we thank you again
that you have given us an opportunity to
come together to study your word to
study the gift of Prophecy you've given
to this church father today is the day
of preparation your Sabbath draws near
and father as much as we may be able to
physically prepare for the Sabbath yet
you alone can spiritually prepare us for
the blessing you have in store prepare
our hearts and our minds to receive the
Sabbath blessing the fullness of it and
the sweet Fellowship that comes with it
we ask and pray these things in Jesus
name amen
I wanted to touch on one more thing
before we jump into this and that was
had an interesting Bible Study last
night didn't we Royce
and um Royce and Rochelle did an
excellent job in this study one thing I
talked to him about and I did talk to
Pastor ashrik last night when you go on
a study you usually go one personally
doubt and the other is a silent partner
you know when you pray
but don't feel like the partner can't
say anything you know sometimes it's
like well I better not say anything
because I'm a silent partner
um and and we were talking about a
little bit last night like have you ever
heard on the radio you ever hear dead
air you know what dead air is what's
dead air
that's when there's no noise
that's that's uh
that's one of the one of the Ten
Commandments for radio is Thou shalt not
have dead air because when you have dead
air somebody's going to say I don't know
what's going on here and change the
station okay dead air is a No-No in the
Bible study you don't want dead air if
you're if you're a person leading out
the study is looking for something and
there's a dead space
make conversation I mean obviously if
you're in the study make it spiritual
but if you're the partner say while he's
looking that up I just thought I'd
mention this don't allow dead air
you follow what I'm saying that you know
the reason now and I taught Pastor Asher
you know highlighted because they've
gone over this with you in class that as
a rule the person who's giving the study
is talking not the partner okay but the
problem is you know the the and the
reason for that is you don't want two
people trying to lead the study okay
because then you you know the guy the
guy or the girl who's trying to lead the
stun he has a train of thought and the
other person comes in and derails the
train so you don't want that but at the
same time the Lord has both of you there
or three of you there or whatever
so that you can complement
do you follow that does that make sense
and and what happens is if you study for
with a person for a while like I can go
on a study with my brother Jim
because he and I have studied so much
together and I can start something and
he can finish it boom just like that and
so we can do the study together like
that and you'll pick up you need to let
the Lord lead in the way that you team
together but remember you are a team and
even as one is going to be praying most
of the time that doesn't mean you can
never bring a thought in because like I
was talking to Royce Royce is on the
spot here's a guy who's resistant
to what he's saying he says your voices
says this is the Antichrist says I don't
see it that way and now he's got
objections so Royce's mind is consumed
with trying to handle the problem he
doesn't have time to stop when you're in
the study you're on
you know you're on stage now there's
nothing you can't go back and rehearse
anything out it's it's it's live
and so he's got to go and he doesn't
have time to stop and process whereas
the partner may be able to process a
little bit because they're not quite you
know they're not as much on the spot to
be able to
maybe help out with some things do you
understand that just something to think
about and pray about I had a hand over
here is he cute did you have your hand
up
huh oh yeah you know I mean when a
person's under conviction yeah and you
see and they're deliberating over
something you don't want continual noise
but the point is when you're giving the
study and you're in the middle of the
study you want to make sure that it
keeps flowing okay
does everybody understand that
okay just just a just a thought to throw
out there and you want to pray we need
to pray for all these studies that are
going on
I mean because the Lord has sent uh each
one of you to the places you're going
for a reason
and so uh and even if they don't accept
Right Here and Now what you're sharing
when you're going out on studies doesn't
mean they haven't accepted it Lori can
do wonders while you're gone
you know I've often as a pastor has
taken me a long time to learn that
you know sometimes I feel like I need to
be there to give the conviction but you
know I've it's dawned on me that you
know what the Holy Spirit can be there
24 7 and he gets a lot further than I do
and so just remember that in your
studies
we're on the handout dealing with
hermeneutic principles how what did the
prophet mean by what the prophet said
we're on page five in fact we finished
page five but I want to recap because
we're still in that topic of policy and
principle somebody tell me what a policy
is
it's an applied principle what's another
word we could use for it a rule
okay a policy would be a rule what is a
principle
the reason behind the rule
what was that
[Laughter]
he's reading the handout good good
that's better than saying nothing so
all right so policy and principle we
talked about yesterday how we need to
understand what policy is and what
principle is if you mistake a policy for
a principle you can get into some big
trouble because you're going to be
trying to apply things for example horse
watering troughs every block
if you mistake that for a principle
um
you're going to have a lot of unneeded
expense for one
and you're probably going to have some
some
resistance from the city
on that as far as ordinances go you kind
of follow what I'm saying there
um it's important to understand what is
policy and what is principle one of the
things we talked about yesterday was the
bicycle Ella might talk about the
bicycle and in fact I was talking how
many of you know who Mary burnt is
okay I was talking with Mary yesterday
and she says brother she says I was at a
church I don't know how long ago she
said she said I got there on Sabbath I
went there with my I had Bible study
interests I took them to church he said
the sermon that Sabbath was on the evils
of riding a bicycle
and she said I just said you know I've
got my interest here and they're like ah
we're not supposed to have bicycles
okay that's what can happen when you
misapply
principle and policy you take a you take
a policy and you don't understand the
principle behind it you're going to be
giving some crazy you know uh anyway
information like that
um
training for young women we looked at
yesterday letter B girls learning to
harness and drive a horse I'm not saying
you can't do that ladies if you'd like
to but I'm going to say that that's
probably not going to be as practical
today as maybe some other things how
many of you own horses and ride them on
a regular basis you've got one of you
here so you know how to harness and ride
a horse you need to
uh the rest of you like I said if you
want to learn that that would be okay
but the policy or the principle rather
behind that policy is to be prepared for
emergencies okay
don't be one of these ladies and these
days even one of these men who stand
beside the road with a flat tire gone
like that right
I don't know what to do
you follow that
okay the next one letter c
vegetarian diet
this is not a
policy this is a a rather this is a
policy not a principle
the vegetarian diet is not an eternal
principle if it were follow me carefully
Jesus never would have eaten fish Jesus
would never have eaten a Passover land
you follow that
when we get into some of these dietary
issues you know this is one of the we're
going to talk on this a little bit more
as we get into extremes now
remember yesterday time can change an
alter situation conditions right time
and Circumstance can change things
uh in fact well I'll read you the
statement after the break I have a
statement by Ellen White where she makes
this point that those who have the light
that we have who continue to eat the
Flesh of dead animals have no evidence
they're walking in safe paths
okay
and it's even a little more pointed than
that when I read the statement you know
so somebody's going to say pastor's
telling us we shouldn't be vegetarians
no we have Good Counsel on vegetarianism
but the point is this if it were a
policy we would not baptize people who
were still eating meat
but as a church we do baptize people who
are still eating meat and we urge them
towards a healthier diet we don't
baptize them if they're eating the
unclean the biblically unclean meats you
follow that but if a person's a meat
eater we baptize them and we try to
introduce them then to a healthier way
do you follow that
vegetarian diet is a policy the
principle is Health the principle right
there is found for one in First
Corinthians 10 31 whether you eat or
drink or what whatever you do do all to
the glory of God now I mentioned Dr
Cress yesterday in the eggs okay the
same situation if you read read the five
chapters in the book when you have
opportunity uh incidentally that's
another thing I started out you had I
had you reach chapter two the other day
uh I've I figured
I think correctly that you had a pretty
full week
so I didn't give you reading assignments
okay
so somebody may say well we got the book
and we didn't go through any of the book
um I hope you're not offended by that
but I figured you had enough to do this
week the book is an excellent resource
though and there's five chapters on the
development of our health message and
you will find that Ellen White into her
late years even after adopting a
vegetarian diet still ate meet at times
why
don't forget they did not have
refrigeration in Illinois today they
didn't have Meyer where you could go
down and buy anything that you wanted
you couldn't get the fresh produce you
wanted I mean they didn't have the
conveniences so there were times these
people were Pioneers man they lived off
the land
and there were times when they were in
situations where they had to go out and
kill what they ate and Ellen White talks
about it in her writings talks about
time and Jameson took out the boys we
killed some ducks and we had dinner you
know or whatever
um
But as time would say
unclean
I'll tell you what there's another issue
Ellen White ate oysters
and people made a big deal about it
and uh some people you'll find these
things on the website Oh Ellen White ate
oysters but something people don't
understand it's in the book on the
health principles is that in those days
there's a question came into the review
and I think it was little John that
answered the question I don't know it
may have been one of the other ministers
that answered it but they asked is are
oysters unclean and he said from the
evidence that we have we're not sure
see you and I today know oysters has
shell vision is unclean but they were
not clear on it then see so we say oh
they're eating oysters
or duck duck is still debated do you
know that people still debate duck is
duck clean or unclean I think as a rule
we take it for being unclean yet you
know and I haven't read I have to go
back and review but when Ellen White had
the duck you know we're still debating
it today is it clean or unclean you know
so they went out and ate what they could
get
yeah the difference the difference I
would say with the oyster says any type
of shellfish feed on
feed on garbage and so put it very
mildly but the only point is over there
were things they didn't understand fully
so we see that on the surface and we say
oh wow she was out you know
um Ellen White followed in fact she says
in her own writings that I've always in
fact look at the uh quote there from
council's on diets and Foods
380. among those who are waiting for the
coming of the Lord meat eating will
eventually be what
done away flesh will cease to form a
part of their diet if we move from what
principle in these things then we may
exert an influence upon others in this
matter which will be pleasing to God and
that's not the quote I was thinking of
that's a good quote uh there's a quote
in which element says I've always held
ever since I've received the light I've
always held to the health principles
that Lord has given me and yet you see
as she goes through her life that her
diet changed you know especially in her
later years she she got away from all
meat eating there's a point where she
claimed and it's in the book we're not
going I don't have time to get to the
detail of all these things but she
claimed that
um she had been a vegetarian for uh oh
she said basically the statement goes
something like this all Adventists are
vegetarians some of them eat fish
she considered a vegetarian at the time
somebody who ate fish and then she goes
on her statements get more direct later
on in her years that we need to abstain
from All Flesh foods every creature you
know and anything that had a mom as we
say sometimes so do you do you
understand the point there Jesus we run
into this problem I mean Pastor Richard
o'fall made kind of made a little uh
remark one time he says you know he says
I've I'm doing pretty good he says I've
got one thing up on Jesus I figure he
said Jesus ate fish and I'm a vegetarian
you see there are people that get a
mindset that they start to view this as
you know you got to be careful
to to try to put some construction on
something that isn't there you know
Jesus ate meat would he do it today I
don't believe he would at all I don't I
don't believe Jesus would eat any Animal
product today personally because of the
disease in the animal kingdom for
Optimal Health
um some of you haven't studied into this
and I'll tell you what the best thing
you know one thing Ellen White said when
we get into talking about health
first of all couple points here
since we're talking about it when we're
dealing with health
remember that Ellen White didn't just
talk about diet
she talked about fresh air
she talked about exercise she talked
about getting Sunshine right she talked
about rest
Temperance Etc you know the natural
doctors
a lot of times we got people who magnify
Health I've got people who come up and
they're real this is how it's got to be
in hell they exercise like this
you understand what I'm saying don't
talk to me about your health message
if you're only keeping one little piece
of it don't tell me how firm you are to
counsel
you follow that
the health messages is a very broad
message it takes in our entire Health
not just our diet
and um
when it came to health
there was a thought I had it's fleeted
right now
where was I going with that
Kevin
come on brother help me out where's
Daniel the Prophet when you need him
anyway it'll come back because we're
going to pick up on health again anyway
Her counsel on health though
um
was a was a very
what I want to say very comprehensive
View
and she also said that the health reform
was Progressive oh that's
praise the Lord what she also said one
of the statements she said is that
everybody
ought to have a working knowledge of the
physiology of the human body
and I'll tell you right now if you
understood how the body works you
wouldn't have questions on health reform
you wouldn't have questions Mary burnt
does a does a presentation if you have
not heard it get a copy David can get
you a copy uh called carnivore or
herbivore
and she basically shows the difference
between a carnival carnivorous animal
and an herbivorous animal never heard
that word before quite that way
and shows the difference with the
construction of the
the physiology okay and then she shows
the results what the results would be if
an herbivore started eating like a
carnivore
and the results
are heart disease
clogged arteries
and all these other things diabetes and
all these other things we're dealing
with it's incredible when you understand
the physiology of the human body you
won't have so many questions about
health reform so but that's the problem
is a lot of people don't understand the
physiology of the body
you know you need to understand
you know God's given us a lot of things
uh to help us to get a grasp on why we
do what we do
so
are you with me on that
yes okay the next item there is Sabbath
observance I want you to look at a
couple things here
Child Guidance page 528. on Friday she
says Let the preparation for the Sabbath
be completed see that all the clothes
all the clothing is in Readiness and
that all the cooking is done let the
boots be black and the baths be taken
okay what's the
principle
okay be ready why
so you can rest on Sabbath now I
preached a sermon on Mary and Martha
okay what was the deal with Mary and
Martha
Mary was where
at the feet of Jesus where was Martha
busy doing everything
Martha missed out on the time at Jesus
feet because she was busy working
on the Sabbath Jesus doesn't want us to
be so busy with our work
that we don't have time to spend with
our special guest you follow that that's
why you need to be and I'll tell you
just like we said the other day when it
comes to standards the person who values
their relationship with Christ the most
will be the most ready for the Sabbath
right
the principle is being ready now look at
some of the things boots being blacked
baths being taken let's take baths being
taken there are some people say don't
take a bath on the Sabbath don't take a
shower on the Sabbath stop for a minute
and think about that I thought that was
hilarious now listen
what was involved in Ellen White's day
and taking a bath
you had to draw the water you had to go
out and pump it out of the well then you
had to get the water in wherever you
were going to do it or take it the bath
outside but depending on the time of the
year and then you had to heat the water
or you could have taken a cold bath but
even a cold bath would have taken a lot
of time wouldn't it today you can jump
in the shower and be out in five minutes
except for some of you guys probably 15
or 20.
if you're like my wife
we take showers differently she likes to
take the she likes to stand in the hot
shower and I like to get in and out
now come on some of you guys are the
ones that like to stand in that shower
oh you know come on fess up anyway
I didn't say there was anything wrong
with that
I'm not faulting her for it but I'm
telling you this
um
I am telling you this the idea here was
preparation for the Sabbath okay and so
if you if I from my perspective to
reapply that principle I don't see that
Ellen White would condemn that today
taking a shower or a bath on the Sabbath
um unless you just get really unless you
take very complicated baths did somebody
have hand-ups
oh okay
next statement look at this one this is
an interesting one and I I I'll share
with you after I read it signs of the
Times May 25 1882 the violation of the
fourth Commandment is not confined to
the preparation of food
many carelessly put off blacking their
boots and what
shaving until after the beginning of the
Sabbath this should not be done
if any neglect to do such work on a
working day they should have respect
enough for God's holy time to let their
beards remain unshaven their boots rough
and brown until Sabbath is passed this
might help their memory and make them
more careful to do their own work on the
six working days
now
does Ellen White would you take that
today and say you can't shave on the
Sabbath
what would be involved in shaving
straight edge and what
strap and go on and hit and heat up the
water and get the water just like the
bath it's a little more complicated than
taking the electric razor in the car
which I often do
okay
do you follow that but now are you clear
with me are you with me on that one now
let me tell you something though I don't
shave on the Sabbath
and I have actually gone in I went I
read this to my church one time I went
in I went in on shaven and they're like
Pastor you didn't shave today several
people commented and I went and I said
look uh this is why I didn't now do I
think it was a total violation let me
put it this way
could I have done that preparation
earlier
yes or no and that's the question
sometimes I think don't look for
loopholes in obeying the Lord
okay and I'm not telling you that you've
got to not shave on the Sabbath but I am
telling you is this from my perspective
when I saw something that I could have
done and it was my neglect that kept me
from doing it and I waited until okay
now all my work is done now it's Sabbath
now I can take care of what I should
have taken care of before that's the
whole point that she's making here then
I then as a as a little rebuke to myself
I said no I'm not going to do it I
should have been ready you follow that
so I you've got to apply the be careful
when you're taking these policy
principle viewpoints and to to well I'll
touch on in a little bit but you get the
point there between policy and principle
okay the next statement uh or the next
uh number four use common sense and
Sanctified reason now
you know David and I were talking last
night you mentioned that this dad used
to say you know if if common sense is so
common why doesn't anybody have it
okay so I like the way I think this was
Roger or it could have been Herbert
Douglas that put it in this phrase uh
common sense and Sanctified reason
because sometimes our Common Sense may
not be that common it may not be make
that much sense either it may just get
us give us a loophole so use common
sense to sanctify reason again three
selected messages page 217 God wants us
all to have common sense he wants us to
reason from Common Sense remember this
was in reference we talked the other day
to people enrolling their kids in school
in kindergarten and people said well
sister white says it and we're going
right up to it she says hold on a minute
we didn't even have Adventist schools
there now your kids are running around
like wild banshees all over the
sanitarium grounds you know if that's
going to be the case put them in school
you got to use a common sense she says
God wants us all to reason from Common
Sense circumstances alter conditions
circumstances change the relation of
things and one thing that I appreciate
so much about the spirit of Prophecy is
it's very sensical
and if a person doesn't have an
inclination that Ellen White is a
prophet and just reads her material
their response usually is wow that's
awesome that must be inspired that just
makes sense
so I appreciate the spirit of Prophecy
for that reason but you and I can take
things
out of their context
and they don't make sense at all you
follow that
the next statement counsels on or no
counselors to teachers is that right CT
I'm I think it's councils to teachers we
are to be guided by the by true Theology
and common sense so there's the sanctify
reason if your common sense is in is not
in accordance with the word of God it's
not common sense at all okay it's a
lunacy so keep that in mind uh and then
beware of extremes and we're going to
talk about that in section D okay next
point in the hermeneutic uh in the in
the in the heronitics next principle
number five
know the difference between true and
apocryphal statements the definition of
apocryphal in case you don't know it is
that of questionable authorship or
authenticity erroneous or fictitious now
I hate to break the news to some of you
but Ellen White never said anything
about the Ark of the Covenant being
discovered in the last days
there are statement there are videos
there are Big Island white says the
coming the Covenant is
if you've got questions on some of these
things go to the
whiteastate.org the website and they've
got a page called documents and they go
into they study all this stuff or it
could be you know I'll have to look it
up at the break biblical Research
Institute I don't know what their
address their email is or the website is
right off the top of my head one of
those two sites deals with this issue
but it's not there
and it's been passed on from one to
another to another and people say Helen
White says
be careful when you're you we read the
statement the other day where Ellen
White says there are things that come
back to me
then I don't even recognize
okay
be aware before you I want to tell you
something
before I quote
you know the devil's got me on a couple
occasions but as a rule before I quote
before I State anything in scripture
before I quote anything from Spirit of
Prophecy I check the validity of it
in the scripture I check the context of
it I have seen people take things and
twist them out of context and uh it's
taught this way and taught this way and
I'm going to preach it and I say well
hey I remember hearing this so and so
say this and so I look up the text and I
read it and I'm going like that's not
what it says I can't use that
know the difference between authentic
and apocryphal statements uh Melchizedek
being the Holy Spirit have you ever
heard this one
people say oh yeah Ellen White says and
here's what they'll say
Ellen White says somewhere I don't know
where but I know I read it
and uh just beware when you hear that
this is probably not in there okay we've
got the CD-ROM you can search this stuff
out and there are occasions when
somebody hasn't heard of it but it may
be in there but know the difference for
yourself there's no statement that
Melchizedek is the Holy Spirit
there are a lot of statements that go
around there's a statement that I have
been passed around
I mean I don't know how to handle them
sometimes there's a statement I've
received in a couple churches
but I I had a guy one day I came into
church and he passes out this little
card he had one for every member of the
church and it said
and I don't have the exact quote or I
should say misquote here that uh the
last mediatorial work of Christ before
he finishes his work in the Heavenly
sanctuaries to gather back those young
uh those children who have strayed from
the faith
have you ever read that
he handed this out to all the church
you'll see it somewhere it's not there
she didn't write it I couldn't find it
on the CD-ROM I'm like I can't find this
thing and I so I wrote in the white
estate they said ah yeah Elder fagel
says I can help you find it
um but it's not in Alan White's writings
it's in one of our source books had an
appendix called the apocryphal writings
of Ellen White
and that's where it was somebody had
passed it around probably had picked up
the idea and thought that it was you
know maybe read something by Ellen White
and then rephrased and rephrased and by
the time it got out it was like oh it
got reworded this way printed down
somewhere and then passed around okay I
don't know how they originate
know the difference okay
before you quote it
you with me on that one okay
number six allow for the maturing
experience of profits
letter A not contradictory keep this in
mind Ellen White grew spiritually you've
heard that now some people will say that
and then they'll make it like she
changed her theology we're going to
touch on that in the next study one
thing I hear is oh after the 1888
General Conference Ellen White changed
her theology have you heard that we're
going to talk about that in our next
session
but
she did her theology didn't change she
never contradicted what she said but I
told you for example the other day
spiritual gifts volume one was this
little tiny book and then it was
expanded to a spiritual gifts one uh two
three and four it was the the set was
expanded and then it was expanded to
Great controversy volumes I'm sorry
Spirit of Prophecy volumes one two three
and four and then that was expanded to
the conflict of the ages series okay how
the Lord would show her upon subsequent
Visions she would get more detail more
understanding and she would write more
let me give you one example great
controversy you've heard some of the
debate about great controversy right the
original book was 400 pages and the
newer book is 650 or 700 pages and it's
all been added and it's all been
plagiarized and it's all been listened
Ellen White between the writing of
spirit of Prophecy Vol 4 which was the
initial great controversy and the 1888
edition of a great of great controversy
where the big expansion took place in
the added Pages took place
in the interim she went to Europe
and in Europe she visited all those
places and she said one thing Ellen
White said about her Visions I wish I
had time to share all of these things
there's a vision she had I'm just going
to tell you what the vision was
um where it was this book here is of
um
Ellen White and her critics by FD nickel
we have written so many books to deal
with Ellen White's critics
I mean and it's the same thing over and
over again it's the same charges but in
the appendix appendix C in this book on
page 558
uh James White had written this account
of Ellen White going to a place where is
this again it's in Michigan
the Bushnell congregation
Ellen White went with James White to
this congregation to speak and when she
was speaking as she got up to speak
the Lord and me Lord brought to mind
something he had shown her previously
and Ellen White's description of her
Visions in many places was that God
would show her things that then she
would forget about until the time came
when that was pertinent and then she
says like a like a flash of lightning
it's flashed into her mind and
immediately the vision came back
and she recalled what she didn't even
what she hadn't even remembered One
account was when she walked into uh
was it the review office either the
review or the Pacific press maybe one of
you remember this
and God had shown her the condition of
some of these men in this building and
she went and never been there before
saw the workers in there and she says
where's the brother that does this
he's not here because the Lord brought
it back she had a testimony for him and
he wasn't there she'd never been there
she didn't know the guy she didn't know
he was employed there other than that
she'd seen a division when she walked in
the Lord said brought it right to mind
the Bushnell vision
element stands before the congregation
and in the Lord flashes into her mind
the vision she had seen previously and
she begins to tell these church members
that the Lord has shown her things in
regard to them and she begins to point
out sister so and so brother so and so
boom boom boom right there in the
congregation this is where and each one
after she had shared that stood up and
testified that what she said was exactly
true
I mean just we there's so many accounts
of the the gift and how it was exercised
well when she was in Europe same thing
she would go to a place in the Alps
where uh and immediately it would flash
into her mind what the Lord had shown
her previously and she saw she would be
standing in the spot where the Walden
seeds were persecuted and she would be
standing by a cave where they had hid
and the Lord would bring it to her mind
okay and then she said in the night
visions oh I'm sorry in in the yeah
um in fact
as she was writing great controversy
I forget who it was who was staying near
Ellen White's house in Elms Haven I
believe it was Elms Haven she wrote the
book in and uh
Willie white uh they're one of the one
of the workers there had noticed a light
coming from Ellen White's room very
early in the morning an incredibly
bright light
and he asked the next morning at
breakfast or in the after breakfast he
saw Willie white and he asked him you
know what what is this you know he
commented on what he'd seen and Willie
responded this way he said mother says
the angel Gabriel visits her in the
ninth season to bring refresh her mind
on the things that she's seen as she's
writing and preparing the manuscript for
the great controversy
I mean and so when she went to Europe
and she saw these things and the Lord
brought them fresh to her mind so that
as she wrote them down
you know it would be more it would have
more point to it okay and there are
chapters in The Great controversy like
the chapter
is it Husson Jerome that was not in the
original great controversy just more
there's a lot more in the reformers most
of the expanded content in the later
edition of great controversy comes from
the Reformation in Europe because when
she went there all of these things came
to mind in one instance they went into a
castle in Europe she'd never been to
Europe never been to the castle and
acted as the tour guide through the
castle multiple rooms because of what
she'd seen in vision
I mean
you know
you know what a straw man argument is
what's a straw man
what is a straw man
literally a scarecrow
and a straw man argument is an argument
to scare people away because if you
investigate it the thing Falls to Pieces
okay these are straw man arguments all
these things about the gift of Prophecy
I mean we just have so much powerful
evidence on this gift
and so the expansion of her books she
matured in experience and God
enlightened her as she grew it was not
contradictory but there was more content
and you see different writing style her
handwriting change we're going to look
at that a little bit because some
critics will look at alamite's
handwriting and they'll say well she
didn't write this because it's different
from this back here because we have the
manuscript it's still her handwriting
I'll talk about that as we come up to it
let's look at that statement three
selected messages page 71. uh top of
page seven
under the expansion of books for 60
years she says I have been in
communication with Heavenly Messengers
and I have been constantly learning in
reference to Divine things and in
reference to the way in which God is
constantly working to bring Souls from
the error of their ways to the light
in God's light
um she grew in her experience
do you follow that
does that make sense
yes sir
oh go ahead
the 1888 Edition
there were some things that were
basically well here's what happened in
1888 the they had printed so many of
them that the plates for printing more
out
and so they had to reset the plates
and while they were resetting the plates
one thing Ellen White always had
counseled was that we not work so hard
at trying to have every last detail of
every one of the things we were going to
publish correct let me not doctrinal but
you know punctuation all that business
before it's published Jan Andrews was
writing the book history of the Sabbath
she said brother Andrews do people need
that book we've got enemies that are
fighting us on this issue of the Sabbath
we need to get that book out there the
Lord's given you that book to get let's
print it and get it out there don't
worry about trying to get every little
thing fixed in it
and so there are errors minor areas of
punctuation there were some references
that they wanted to put in so when they
were going to reprint it they just
basically sat down looked over the
manuscript and says well since we're
reprinting it we're resetting this thing
let's look over it and see what can be
corrected in here they had gotten some
feedback on some phrases that they
thought might read better differently
this one may be offensive I think in uh
I'm not certain that words like romish
you'll find that's in the 1884. great
controversy the first edition of spirit
of Prophecy volume 4 was published in
1884. it may have been changed between
then and 1888 I'm not sure but this type
of thing where they would use the word
romish instead of papal and and or the
romish persecutors well that's an
offensive term to a Catholic more than
papal is and so they said you know let's
change the terminology there so it's not
so in your face you know and things like
that and you can do the book talks about
the expansion of the the development of
her books you can look in here and read
and get more detail on that
um but that's the gist of what those
those changes there weren't a lot of
significant changes between that the
early and the 1911 Edition the main
changes came in with the 1884 and 1888
primarily because that visit to Europe
and uh what more the Lord had revealed
to Ellen White
you follow that the critics make a big
deal out of this and this uh this great
controversy well they make a big deal at
everything we're going to talk more on
that
uh number seven understand the value of
experience letter A
basically this is I I'm just using this
example understand the value of
experience and the people who went
before us some of us think that some of
us wants to sit want to sit as experts
on things that we've never experienced
and let me just give a caution to those
of you younger ones here
you know most of you are fairly young
and uh
you know we're on fire we're going to
these dead churches and these dead
pastors and everything else be careful
sometimes how you regard your own
um
what I want to say spirituality in light
of in in
uh what do I say in contrast to some
others there are people of experience
and and maybe that maybe they aren't as
on fire as they ought to be but there's
a wealth of experience that we would do
well sometimes to heed you know and and
this is what elements Council here is
basically saying you're here you've got
some young people coming on board
questioning some of the earlier
positions we had taken
and uh you know there's a lot of talk
today I'm not going to go into a lot of
detail here on this but like the
trumpets of Revelation
today we say the trumpets of Revelation
that makes little sense I'll be honest
with you it doesn't make as much sense
to me is it you know and we want to try
to reapply and have some futuristic
definition something you have to
understand is that definite those
interpret the interpretation of the
trumpets LED that movement to a
conviction on the truths of Revelation
in the Bible in the remnant Church
in that experience they were Elemental
those things were essential in their
experience of our Pioneers they went
through the experience
and you and I can't have half an
understanding I I had I heard a speaker
once make this point and I just cringed
he said
um
he was reading the book synopsis of the
present Truth by James White Uriah Smith
and he said you know and this guy is big
on the gospel he thinks he's got the
gospel all figured out like some people
do and he said I went through that book
and that book had nothing about present
truth in it
you know he was just saying these
Pioneers James White and people say
similar things our Pioneers didn't
understand righteousness by faith
that didn't come until 1888 let me tell
you something
the all of us today who understand
righteousness by faith oh we're so
gospel centered
if we had to endure the great
disappointment I wonder how few of us
would be standing
the test of experience is not what we
think we know
those people pass through the
disappointment and held on to Christ
they understood righteousness by faith
better than a lot of us do in their
practical experience and I think that's
what elamite is saying here 1888
materials Pages 738 and 739 we met oh we
met a very intelligent young man who is
all together filled with the idea that
no one is quite as smart as himself
he has been studying the messages in
Revelation and he thinks he has
discovered wonderful light but it is not
that wonderful light which will flash
forth all along the pathway till the end
of time notice all along the pathway see
these futurists want to put all the
interpretations of Revelation at the end
the Book of Revelation was to take us
from John's day and give light all the
way
if God just gave light for those of us
at the end of time in the Book of
Revelation though we're not life is easy
for us
you had people get they had to give
their lives men women children tortured
to death during the Dark Ages and God
gave them nothing not even a little
crumb to hang to to grab onto for hope
no The Book of Revelation was written to
God God's people all the way through
and this is what she's saying all along
the pathway it will flash forth till the
end of time she says of this young man
his theory it is a theory that tears
away and takes the vitals out of all the
past experience in the messages to see
such a youth of a Babe's experience
turning away the pillars of our faith
seems just terrible
those who had no experience in this are
not the ones to be proper judges of it
and the next one there from manuscript
releases volume 760 your manuscript
release at 760 page 19. men will arise
with the interpretations of with
interpretations of scripture which are
to them truth but which are not truth
the truth for this time God has given us
as a foundation for our faith he himself
has taught us what is truth one will
arise and still another with new light
which contradicts the light that God has
given under the demonstration of his
holy spirit
a few are still alive who have passed
through the experience gained in the
establishment of this truth God has
graciously spared their lives to repeat
and repeat till the close of their lives
The Experience through which they passed
even as John the Apostle till the very
close of his life
and the standard bearers who have fallen
in death are to speak through the
reprinting of their writings I am
instructed that thus their voices are to
be heard they are to Bear their
testimony as to what constitutes the
truth for this time
and I just want to tell you briefly is
the book still up here great second
Advent movement I had here the other day
those books
I think I put it back
if you read the books of the Adventist
Pioneers they don't read like books
today
their Bible studies
and a lot of people don't read them
because we I'll be honest with you we
like cheap frivolous stuff to read
we really do
and uh
if I didn't say this already I need to
say it now the best way for you to
understand the gift of Prophecy in our
church is not for the to come to this
class
it's to read it
and it's to apply it
in your own life
and a lot of times a lot of us are very
I mean think about this for a minute
God sends a message to his last day
Church okay we've got the scripture God
sends a message you know it's from God
imagine you imagine an angel comes in
you have word that an angel comes down
and you know super spiritualism
everything let's just imagine for a
minute that it's not we know it's true
word is that there is a person that's a
period of spirit well I'm not even going
to go there let's go a prophet
word is it God has risen up another
prophet in the Adventist Church
and they had a vision and they have a
testimony for God's people
and we and and it's true
how long would it take you to get a hold
of that testimony to read it
would you say ah I guess I get around to
that sooner or later if you were
convinced God has risen yeah they spoke
out at the church there in in La Sierra
and straightened things out
amen
and uh I wanna and
and let's just say though that this you
know you know you're thinking well is it
true Prophet is it let's just assume it
was a true prophet but they they gave
testimony for God's church and what we
need to do the Lord's coming soon in the
in the in the final movements are right
upon us and etc etc and you hear about
this and you've got this would you want
to read that
would you want to read it pretty quick
what do you want to get your hands on it
right away and yet what do we do with
the spirit of Prophecy
well I got a new book by Max Lucado it's
just it warms my heart
I'm not telling you not to read Max
Lucado but I'm telling you we don't read
enough of the spirit of Prophecy we are
we are unfamiliar with the spirit of
Prophecy
I asked the other day who knows the
Oxford what the Augsburg confession is
nobody knows what the Augsburg
confession is you haven't made great
controversy
if you didn't raise your hand great
you know what book Ellen White said was
the book she wanted everybody you wanted
to go out more than any other book
was the steps to Christ wasn't Desire of
Ages it was a great controversy now I
ask myself this I thought to myself my
brother and I were talking about it why
great controversy I mean you know versus
Desire of Ages or something
and he answered this way and I thought
he was right on the money
he said you know Desire of Ages is for
people who have an interest in spiritual
things
but great controversy creates an
interest
and that's what the world needs today
and so
I noticed I'm going over here so let's
take a break and uh we'll come back in
and pick up here in 10 minutes all right